[Music]
welcome to the mommy dome pull your
jeans up over your eyes tonight we are
all poly and buy make sure you get your
mousse soup and plenty of water now
please ladies and gentlemen let's
welcome to the stage drama Christina
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that is my bottle of water that I
brought out anyway what's up everybody
how you guys doing tonight thanks for
coming out
where's your water Tom that's right
fucking here it's not it's sober October
I know it's not boring are you guys
doing it to sober October fuck now yeah
fucking losers that's what you are they
were like no who asked that Bert he came
over he's like hey push how come you
never do these contests I'm like cuz I'm
not fucking retarded yeah oh nice to say
that that's not do you want to be
involved in what in the crowd yeah no
what about 90-minute yoga so that's it's
arable I actually picture you in there
dying I would die oh it's so fucking
fast I wouldn't like it at all
no no quit you quit I would do it if it
was like Road rules 2017 and there's
like there's a prize free oh I feel like
you get a motorcycle if you make it to
the end of the thing yeah you can write
it through Vietnam yes yeah what do you
what do you win for doing this but I
don't know this is the worst bet I've
ever been involved in because there's
also no stakes yeah there's still no
stakes like for the weight loss bet
there were stakes like there was you'd
be publicly humiliated which you were
even if you want action you have your
beard shaved by the other person and
you're supposed to pay for a trip it's
like others all these tears of things at
stake for the sobriety hot yoga one
you're like okay what if I fuck up when
I do
they're like then you just know that the
guy you're like okay so that's true
maybe I will get super drunk all month
and just not say it until the months
over and be like I lost I guess like
that I lost and there's no ramifications
for losing but the problem is there's no
it's all it's all the honor system right
yeah bullshit do you think that Bert is
being honest no no right
I wanted the scram bracelet I feel like
that would have been so fuck I know like
a convict you guys I think we could have
done it but like you know sometimes you
see that look in someone's eye when
they're like are you really gonna do
that to me like that and when I saw that
his face I was like all right like honor
system don't fucking start crying right
now
so but I feel like we're all doing it
honestly just for him seriously
no really that's why we're doing it it's
it's all it's basically to get Bert to
be sober in October that's the whole
reason like everyone else is really
funny I'll do it too it's not hard but
I'll do it too I think it's hard for Ari
Ari is struggling with the the weed
aspect for sure and he's annoyed he's
really annoys looking you think he's the
ugliest of all of you for sure really
you know what's crazy
there are women that find him attractive
and I'm always like like why and they're
like but they're always like they're
always like fucking chicks like I love
her you always do women that way I don't
always do women that it's always the
calm guzzlers that are like that
yeah like chicks that would look at RI
me like yeah it's like yeah yeah where's
the calm yeah
what are you looking for it what do you
think like what's his game like you know
you always talk about guys that have
their different games game what's what's
that game I think the appeal of Ahri is
that he is he's not tied down he's like
really free live in life so like
somebody sees him as somebody he has
nothing holding him down from doing
anything like ever let's go to like
Thailand tomorrow he does that he'll be
like we can come back and fucking
January like you'll just do that so I
think you see like a guy just living his
life freely and just doing what everyone
so there's an appeal of that you know
yeah what kind of girl do you think look
what's the girl just a girl who's
transitioning from like a bad place in
her life today she's like this will be
like my last fucking it's like you're
like I'm gonna quit drugs tomorrow it's
like yeah it's like the last step before
you you go marry a girl who's like and
this is my last you know like
unemployment check and then and then she
fucks him and she's like what the fuck
am I doing with my life and then she
finally gets her shit together well
thank God Ari's famous because if I mean
if he weren't
there's just pictures of his asshole
everywhere on the internet like could
you imagine googling him now a
researching yeah
learn what your ass smells like put your
cock and balls smell like yeah doesn't
smell good watch the Juke Liam video
that's not a lot of yes well you get out
of here at Google Juke lamb Ari Shaffir
and he has a real serious hemorrhoid
problem
oh it's disguise oh it looks like a
fucking you ever seen like wildlife
monkey ass videos you know when you see
like a monkey's ass at the zoo and
you're like what the fuck and like their
ass is like that big his asshole comes
out and swells up and it looks like like
a monkey's ass look it up top
don't look it up if you don't want to
throw up but look at if you do I noticed
you're not wearing your hat as the new
hack here's the thing I'm so fucking
pissed off I forgot my hat know what I
think in this guy's hat let's go that's
a hat that's a great day you like that
one yeah choo choo yeah I love it
yeah is that what it is that what that
would be considered like a conductor a
sailor yeah all right fucking all aboard
whatever man aye aye captain
I don't know the sailing terms but do
that what the sail get it up
scrape the JibJab there you go do you
sail scram the Chum
do you ever go on boats once in a while
what are you fish you do once wait how
often though be real couple times a year
where do you go out of like where do you
do it San Diego do you go deep-sea where
do you where you can you where do you
fish in there off the beach like oh okay
so you're like a land fisherman you what
you go on boats - all right well then
you can
I respect it I fucking like it yeah I
like I think but see that guy can wear
that hat hey why can he wear it because
look at his hair okay look at the hair
too hat ratio it kind of pokes out like
all cute right like and then he look at
his cute little bracelets see he's got
like this
show us your bracelets like your string
I'm not so sure I thought you know watch
before
shut up look at my cute little bracelet
right here you know words like like
Isaac Brock from modest mouse like
you've got that kind of Isaac Brock
thing yeah do she come from God real
fucking hot for teacher
dudes mean that - yeah hold on let me
take off my matching jacket weird about
matching what are you talking about
they're different colors you would I put
mine on first and then you put yours on
but then it's shiny we look like a dorky
couple look like a matching mom jacket I
don't know what you're fucking talking
about right hey you know when you tell
me to eat the scrum yeah what is that
mean you say eat the scrum means eat my
ass
but where did you come up with that I
don't know I think I heard someone say
and I was like no bend over we'll be
like in our room like at night and he'll
be in his boxer shorts just randomly and
then he'll bend over and be like what
are you gonna eat the scrum but I
thought it might be a fisherman's term
you gotta eat the scum matey
no is this your lady here no you guys
are fuckin friends you ever go fishing
with him you watch the big fish you
catch big fish what do you mean you go
deep-sea fishing oh oh where do you go
really Mexican water she says where I
think of a boat you have to go on to go
to get big fish down there yeah don't
you have to go on a decent-sized boat
wait are you a there's the more money
you have she's saying that you have to
have a lot of money oh no I have like
millions it's all I'm asking like oh my
god what you going to big boats oh you
mean because you have to go with other
people no I would go like on you're
getting more and more elitist in your
old age other people no no so how many
people would you have to go with though
7 d Jesus yeah fuck what size boat is
that you don't know you have no idea she
carries for the fish you don't drive it
ok alright ok captain right
is this the fishing podcaster are we
gonna talk about that that really matter
let's keep it fishy so eat the scrum eat
the scrum
you should eat my scrum
it's a scrum your taint is that what
you're asking sure it's all that why
don't just get up in there and do it all
let me tell you something if I were the
girl that did eat your scrum yeah you
would never marry me like that girl is
the dirty girl that's cool it's not
that's a nasty girl eat the scrum what
are you talking about no it's not
fisherlady
would you eat a scrum hell no no that's
just for hos what if it was like what if
just tell you and it's on a little boat
you got all this money you got all the
fish I kind of flipping around there
like there wait there gasping their last
breath of air the mood is set well yeah
all right all right ready let's open the
show the right way normal chicks don't
all right here we go let's do it here we
go I had 5,000 ounces of my breast milk
stored in my freezer my name is
Elizabeth I am a mass milk producer oh
don't bring anyone love into this
[Applause]
welcome to your palms house with town
[Music]
yeah thank you for coming out tonight to
the sperm vine improv here in sperm city
California
appreciate you guys coming out giving us
your Sunday evening a lot has gone has
happened this week what you had to bring
that up what do you want me act like
they're not dead now Tom Petty's dead ah
yep that's that's it show's over
Ralphie made I'd know why we liked
Ralphie he was and you know what was
about cool about Ralphie is that he was
legit a nice human being and in our
business that is really fuckin rare like
he was always kind no matter what right
like you never shitty to any super
sweetheart I would run in him sometimes
on the road I Brandon doing radio
stations a couple times yep nice always
the nicest guy really sweet guy sucks it
really does suck no I mean he was like
he's almost as fat as bird and then ah I
see him go like that was just unexpected
me I think did Bert comment on the
Instagram post you made where you were
like rest in peace Ralphie and then you
put a picture of Bert yeah he he wrote
back
he wrote Ravi didn't write to me Bert
wrote back to me
well first of all Ralphie by the way if
you knew him he loved when people went
in hard on jokes loved it loved like
hardcore like social media jokes he
loved that shit like if you hit like a
raw joke if it was a good joke he loved
it so I knew I my feeling was that he
would you know he would like it yeah but
yeah hurt Bert road to me today he goes
the posy was hilarious
you know but I get impression he told
him yeah I heard him tell this story
this was just one thing we'll leave but
like Burt was telling the story on Diaz
his podcast the other day they did it
they did a podcast right after the night
that Ralphie died and Bert was telling
the story but like you know especially
for like such the story guy he got his
own story wrong because I was watching I
was like I wonder if I tell this story
and they ki told the story about how
they went on a trip together and I think
it was Atlantis in the Bahamas and so
Ralph he was headlining and Bert was
opening all week it was like a you know
a big radio station sponsored thing and
Ralphie had been you know big headliner
for a few years so he bought every meal
right oh this is like we used to go over
to the crashers' house when I was an OBE
like I would be like opening for Bert
who's opening for someone else so we all
that we'd ever had no money we were
fishing with lots of people and we were
like we would we are so we went over
there and and Bert's like oh my god he
and he was like we got he was they
pulled me aside so I got a big fight
with the end this week and I was like
what happened and he goes well we're in
the Bahamas Ralphie's buying US lunch
and dinner every day rest nice
restaurants so the last day I go we're
taking you to dinner and Robbie's like I
play that's cool he's like where do you
want to go and Ralphie's like sushi and
then you know birds like fuck because
he's like to even to anybody goes I want
to go to sushi usually it implies you're
gonna be spending a little more you know
most expensive thing yeah yeah you know
amongst things like all right it's like
yeah it's on me they get there and he
and I go so how much is he my sushi does
he get it was dude it's just like
fucking boat after boat they just bring
boats and and Ralph he's so high that
like so like he's Ralphie he's eating
more than he normally would eat and he
goes and he's so
if he would like dip out and then come
to and be like oh shit I forgot about
that
and then he's like like after four boats
come in he was like fuck we're fucked
you know and then you know he just keep
order and keep ordering and then he goes
that bill comes and he says it on that
show but the bill comes in it was $1,200
which is and and you and I have done a
lot of damage as soon as never done that
no I mean even out like Nobu like the
necking no and we eat a lot of fuckin
soon no I've never I mean and then he
said that and so Lee Ann that the reason
they got in the fight is that Lee Ann's
like how much is it and goes shut the
fuck up I think it was I think the bill
was what he was getting paid to open
that week lesson learned don't take that
size of a person out to dinner and now
that Rafi was great rest in peace that
piece of shit Hugh Hefner died he died
but I don't like him
here's why I'll tell you why this guy
took his breath away who's that
Christina I know okay well here's why
look here here's my thoughts on on Jews
that was from his eulogy right there
yeah that's what's her name Holly
Robinsons yeah 21 John Street here's why
I feel like those girls first of all you
didn't get paid shit to do that magazine
you lived in the house you bunked with
like four other chicks right you get
paid I don't know what was a stipend a
week it wasn't a lot I know the whole
thing was like you're not you're not
gonna make the the thing was you didn't
get tons of money it was the prestige
fuck am i being the you know the playboy
living in the house and being lifestyle
and and being around him and you know
being
with him right here's the thing so then
you get summoned to his room and old
wrinkled nuts is in this fucking cell
PJ's and then we got to watch a movie
together
you guys got a make-out while a jerk-off
and then I got a butt fuck cuz he was
but fucking people because I don't want
to know this because I'm fascinated but
I'm fascinated by it so here's my point
who was like and then he but fuck no he
would but sex a lot of the girls cuz he
didn't want to have babies
it was on Stern some one of the was on
strike anyway I always liked Larry Flynt
more cuz I felt like it was more honest
like there was no this one none of this
horseshit come live in the mansion in
this book it was like spread it yeah
yeah right
show me your clamp is that right yeah
and it was always this ruse of like this
is classy like no it's dude fucking look
like it's a Jack mag and that's fine but
just be a fuckin jizz rag I still
remember that like you know playboy was
so much more popular and as a kid we
would get our hands on a playboy and be
like whoa like this is wild you know
like a girl you'd see like bush and tits
and then like that first time you see a
hustler and you're like what the fuck
like this is the real shit right here
that's what I'm fuckin around with the
JV squad right dude it's like you ate a
Del Taco your whole life and then you go
to Taco Bell that's not the analogy I
was going with at all okay it's like
McDonald's and in and out it's not being
L&G I mean I guess yeah yeah
way better than Del Taco I would say
yeah dude
oh I'm the fast food chain returning
yeah that's what I would do dude
but I'm the I'm a totem pole of
fast-food restaurants there's nothing
lower than del Taco bros Arby's shit
worst yes
Arby's is foul man I I've met somebody
tutorial that they worked at Arby's and
like in there when they had slow times
they would take that roast beef and
throw it on the wall and they would just
stick there who'd never slide down the
wall this foul shit don't fuck with
Arby's but then again Taco Bell but I
like just like the ratio like the shell
is crunchy and then the sour cream the
meat is dogshit but the flavor is nice
no where do you rank this is funny I
never fart I never had this conversation
until I was working in LA for a while at
this post house with like some pretty
rough characters and and they brought
like I would say like oh let's go to end
now thinking like everybody loves in and
out and these guys would be like in and
outs for bitches I'm gonna be like wait
what and they're like fat burger that's
many what is happening right now and
they were like you like in and out cuz
that sauce and I was like fresh and
delicious and they're like could you
bitch are you a fuck boy yeah yeah
that's kind of what they were saying
I know fat burger was good but it was
had that weird spice to it there's like
relish something spicy right here you
guys like fat burger
yeah that shit's good who likes in and
out though
see I'd rather roll with the bitches and
go to in and out yeah I'm all about to
end our days fucking amazing yeah it is
the sauce it's just Thousand Island with
relish in it right whatever it is yeah
keep fucking making it is this good
could you imagine just back to Hugh
Hefner for a minute second on that D
yeah dude like that's a saying like free
room and board ain't worth it yeah would
you yeah yeah good exposure especially
also here's the thing you gotta take
yourself to being like 21
you know what the exposure lead to okay
so Jenny McCarthy I'd say she's like the
most famous right who else who's who's
like who's a respectable star that came
out I'm being sledge it's serious
I don't know oh very reputable yes
Nobel laureate Pamela Anderson yeah
and another note you could be that one
in 20,000 there you go yeah that's true
yeah it could work out tough racket you
know I think I knew this girl from Road
rules she posed in it cuz at one point
they offered it to a lot of people not
me but Adam she didn't have fucking
pages big enough for those tips I'm
sorry why maybe like well everyone sit
over here and then when they flip it
I'll see if the other tape especially
now holy shit but she was special mom
tits issues yeah purple nips but this
girl was like I go I go so dude you you
did it did you tell your dad and she
goes yeah he was like real proud he took
a bunch of copies to his work and gave
it out to his employees I was all oh
that's so weird I know somebody not with
that scenario but somebody who has a
daughter in a movie and it's not a porn
but the daughter is naked in the movie
and he's like you see that movie with my
daughter and it's like dude yeah I did
this is really good in it he's like I'm
so proud of him like all right yeah take
your mom that's got a nice nips it's so
weird but then I think my dad's gonna
watch my Netflix thing it'd be like
Tuesday her special comes out Tuesday
thank you guys you're very sweet to clap
but imagine like dude it's glass see
Christina do it stand up we're talking
there you go
but on some level my dad's gonna be like
oh my god I can't believe this is my
fucking daughter you know you think so
I'm talking about crazy shit on stage oh
wait what was that
what was that line those are you talking
about our dick sex know what it's called
yeah one hour of dicks sucks that's your
next hour dude I have a name mine yet
I know like the chumps from the champ
scrum the gym even some scrummage you
want to get to the breast milk later all
right I like it because it seems she
says she has 5,000 ounces of breast milk
in her fridge so much it's so hard to
make that much for me anyway how long
would that take you a year I didn't make
a lot when I was doing it it was so hard
like just four ounces was a lot late
hard form see what's up with this taste
situation hold on
I have hyper lactation syndrome my body
makes 1.75 gallons a day I have donated
seven
gallons of my excess breast milk that's
twice the world record wait did you hear
that 1.75 gallons a day tits
fuck do it her titties hanging that big
like minor big oh shit I could I could
deal with these tits they're like hungry
tits no no that's a lot but if she's
giving it to women who can't make breast
milk that's coming good know I'm just
telling it to do is they want to pay for
it she's just like like big tits yeah
there's somebody out there up in the
morning because they're screaming please
do something that's yeah that's terrible
oh I must be with my nuts feel like
sometimes you know sometimes I wake up
like oh god is that right wake up wake
up yeah that's what you that's when
you're like what I'm trying to sleep
that's what it is the same burden that
this woman has I try to donate it as
much as I can do you think if we could
pump your dick milk that you could how
much could you produce is what I'm asked
not 1.75 gallons a day how about one
gallon a day what's not of course not I
mean I'm not talking out of turn you've
discussed this in public you make a lot
like your high producer as Yoshi would
say a strong performer very balanced on
performance would you say you could do
like a half a pint a day no do you
realize how like am i 16 in this
scenario
it is crazy to think about how I get
back then as a teenager go yeah you
could be like if you want to try to do 7
today be like alright alright so what
what would happen now if you tried to
crank out seven no there's what what no
like it's not happening
no it's not happening at all no
definitely not
what's that for come it is such a good
business that never took off as come gum
remember like the tools that you or
tidal wave gum you bite it in the middle
and then it would burst liquid flavor it
would have all the different ethnicities
you know I mean it's like we need more
diversity and that's what it'd be like
Oh what about Indian guys that you'd pop
one in your mouth like oh that's what
that tastes like you like that see I
don't think the audience is really
excited about you're not into it
no I think now there's no way there's no
way there's no way close to that seven
seven milks nope six nope five four I
don't think so
four would be like if you were like I
don't know if you're like if you don't
then somebody's gonna get a bullet in
the head right now be like alright
alright alright but that would be it
then I'd be like Annie to the hospital I
need an IV I'd be like that would really
be nice to me now what were we watching
last night we were talking about all
dudes
oh oh yeah the the Versailles guy the
queen of her side that long story this
old ass motherfucker was how old is he
78 or something up there yeah and he's
still he's still in horny you know he's
still doing like shoulder rubs too
strange flirting with a chick yeah good
point does that stuff taper off I would
think that that's what's so freeing for
a guy to get old and like that you just
like yeah it doesn't really affect me
anymore the power is the pussy power is
gone yeah yeah like we're like a woman
could be like hey and you be like I'm
reading the paper I don't give a shit
you know like
I would think that would be exciting but
he's still like a hundred percent and
she's talking about it
his wife was like oh my god fuck him all
the time she's like 40 years younger
than him and he's like hurry up get over
here Wow it is it is I almost think he
has to be manipulating that like he's
doing something to cause that at his age
viagra like some trucks yeah drug some
type of testosterone treatment something
yeah yeah injection he's way too horny
for an old guy weird man
anyways I'm gonna try to start this just
business but I thought you might know
that okay listen do you want to see this
girl trying to drink vinegar oh well
they can't see it told me to try this
and some water side with that same is
good so she's trying to do this as like
an idea of like a health regimen or yeah
it's very no it's not gonna kill you
[Music]
doesn't smell good and let's see what
happens don't drink it dummy okay so now
she's taking it in here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
ok it's over it's over now it's over it
is over it's over you know what Tom when
I was a little girl yeah I used to love
eating my boogers Oh God oh you guys
never eat your boogers oh no what she's
doing right now when you were little and
I love the ones okay when I dick really
and they're like crunchy on the end but
then like scraggly yeah oh you fucking
nasties you never ate that you are so
nasty oh you do this okay okay all right
it's over it's over it's over every bite
it is I closed it it's over
you swear yes it's over it's not the
worst I hate barfing I know all right
you guys wanted your new segment so I
forget we were in the Starbucks and
there is this fucking weird beard on his
computer just with his feet up on the
furniture like barefoot like yeah like
this is my house fuck it like no it's
not dude and so we were thinking like
that's still fucking nasty dude right
like can we agree that that's all that
is fucking nasty
but then there's stuff that I feel like
is kind of borderline so I got this
email this guy's from Finland
he says I'm recently hanging out with a
bunch of friends with the discipline his
discussion turned to pissing in the
shower
my friends were sharing stories of how
good it feels to let it splash when
taking a shower I immediately expressed
my disgust but was left completely alone
with my stance on the matter
turns out all my friends dabble in
shower pissing
and they made me feel like the weird one
for not mixing golden showers worth
regular ones am I on the wrong here tell
me guys is yes Yeah right you're fucking
weird man of course who doesn't play
shower do you actually it's anyone here
actually are you ever in the shower go I
have to pee and then be like well I'm
just gonna get out now and use the
toilet does somebody do that
that's you do is that a man or a woman
woman wait why wouldn't you just go in
the shower there's a drain do you not
pee in the drain you can't do it Wow but
the hearing kills the bacteria on your
feet how many of you pee in the shower
[Applause]
how many of you don't pee in the shower
Wow Wow
imagine how upset you would be if you're
showering with your significant other
and then you just saw like a orange
stream come out we'd be the end of the
relationship right stab with a fucking
shampoo bottle and that's fun when you
like I like it hot hey that's real hot
what's that and it always smells like
coffee - okay what about is this nasty
or not cuz you just did this last night
farting on the dog's head
because here's the thing is kind of
nasty but then it's funny so the funny
kind of outweighs the nasty yeah and
like we have two dogs and one of them's
into it and one of them's not so beef
hates fire yeah he doesn't like it he's
like farts are gross
but then bits he's like it works I know
the feet on the furniture thing that's
crazy
in public yeah or in somebody else's
place you know like if you go to someone
else's house the fuck are you doing then
that's all your own shit one time in
college I had a fucking like a friend of
a friend come over to my dorm room and
she was wearing her shoes she laid on my
bed and put her nasty shoes on my pillow
bro
yes well people have shoes on like on
the bed it's no crazier shoe that you
walk as nasty like the bedspread crazy I
had somebody who brought their girl to a
show and I'm eating in the green room on
the and it's on the you know like on the
coffee table and she goes do you mind
and put her feet up on the clock and I
was in such shock I was like are you
testing me right now like she had to put
them up you know I was like this is
fucking wild yeah he doesn't open for me
anymore
all right what about blowing your nose
in the shower yeah that's cool right
that's normal
yeah that's not nasty at all wait does
somebody not do that cloud if you don't
blow your nose in the shower see you
guys are the best place to do it yeah
where else you're supposed to do that
shit it's and then you like you have
that guessing game you're like is it in
my beard is it not like it's always in
your beard by the way that's nasty okay
what about being barefoot on an airplane
oh man that's nasties fuck right that's
unacceptable when they put it up on your
armrest
I did one of these ones where I did I I
knocked it over and I was like oh my bad
you know like I hit them hit the elbow
with it that's fucking crazy
okay what about cutting your nails in
public suit that's no that's super nasty
that's okay that might be the top that
is really nice yeah what about painting
your nails in public so it's that's
permissible that's not that's not a
nasty no okay I've done like I've done
like almost all of these putting on
deodorant in public
that's nasty but I've done it yeah but I
think that's one of those things you do
but you try to not make it a public
affair not like check this shit out
you're just like I got to do this and
you you try to conceal a little bit
right yes yes here's what I used to do
for my first years in comedy I would be
so nervous and sweaty that I would have
comedy deodorant like in my car so when
I roll up to like the Laugh Factory I'd
fucking reach on the side pocket and put
deodorant like extra on yeah that's
super nasty no I've never
I don't smell so I've never had that
baby stop
now what about spitting in public
spitting but culturally like Asian
cultures do it and it's fine just all of
the Asian world know Chinese people spit
on them all over the place oh no it's
true
I had a Chinese ex-boyfriend and he
would tell me all the time they spit
everywhere
I think spitting like spitting is one of
those things where like sometimes you
have to do it I feel like it's not as
nasty if you at least make an effort to
spit on grass or bush like something you
know I mean yeah if you're like oh
here's the fucking concrete that's the
difference you're a piece of shit you
know like and also some people like I've
been I've been out to lunch with people
who you walk out of the restaurant
they're like yeah so we should yeah
I want to be like fuck you do this our
last lunch we're not doing this again
it's the nastiest the hot super nasty
what about your booger thing what about
the book you started with boogers well
picking your nose in the car in your own
car everybody picks don't act like you
don't pay everybody picks the Carson
that's penny what's your technique cuz I
like to go oh my god like that but you
do that in my car too
that's the fucking problem do it in your
car elses sneeze on you yeah I know
that's really fun when you feel it
coming you know you finished like that I
love that I know Thanks you're super
nasty so you didn't like the thing that
barfing stuff didn't really put me in a
good place to put you in a good place
please don't dirty I'm not doing it so
we don't we people asked what they asked
about how a blind person yeah I love a
lot of blind questions but how they pick
up dog shit yeah right
and a blind person actually told us
about you didn't know I'm blind and I
have been a guide dog user for more than
10 years now Wow
okay so we have he's very attractive she
is she doesn't even know that though but
I have had a lot of experience picking
up and you know dealing with dog poop
and a lot of people seem to be really
curious about this topic and in terms of
picking it up guy dug schools trained
you on on how to deal with it but for
the most part guy dogs those at least in
school I went to the mirror foundation
training the dog to go on concrete
because the poop is easier to find on
concrete than it is to find in grass and
Wow Oh dogs are amazing on top of that
they train the dogs to typically hover
over where they've gone to the washroom
and then what you do is you put the bag
on your hand you touch your dog's back
and if it's not trained to hover then
you just touch it well it's still going
wow isn't that amazing that dogs can
learn to do a little trace over it
that's so cool and you put your hand
over top of the dog's back with the bag
on and you essentially like feel down to
the ground so right wow the end of the
dog to the floor where the poop and then
poop if your dog has moved you still
know the general area that your dog was
standing because you're holding the
leash in you're right there everybody
that's going and so at that point you
feel around for the heat I know that's
my least favorite part about cleaning of
dog poop is the heat in the bag when
you're like oh that's fresh that's what
I get I get a thrill out of that I was
like I feel alive I know the dogs alive
legs
you're like fresh out of the oven fresh
out of there is just like brownies or
cookies you know you just ah that's a
good time but that's how blind people
know fascinating well we've got some
other fascinating uh questions here yeah
okay well here's a since we're on the
blind one let's go there with all the
blind questions coming in this person
writes with Bart himself I was wondering
if blind people really can get a full
grasp on how fat Burt truly is
that is a really good question I guess
if they met him they would no they
wouldn't now yeah they just go but they
wouldn't know just by hearing him they
wouldn't know this one's about back to
retarded people because we've been
really curious about this this comes in
from Niall Dowd okay he writes to
retarded people have an inner voice
that's retarded it's not very nice
because maybe in here it's it's like how
I think and then and then it comes out
so is that inner voice like man you
should go get that candy right fucking
now or like that I know we didn't write
it somebody else wrote it that's a
really good question regarding you asked
today it's such a funny mean thought
then you you were like do retarded
people have certain jokes that don't
like they really like to tell right like
you know I mean like comics find certain
things funny amongst comics do retarded
people amongst themselves and I thought
like oh yeah those are knock-knock jokes
you know yeah yeah or like dad jokes
yeah I don't know I think like it could
be their own wheelhouse is what you're
saying right yeah yeah it makes sense
like like I'm sure pilots have their own
lingo about like yeah fucking that do
you think retarded be able to tell jokes
about retarded people no yeah for sure
really yeah of course you don't think so
I don't know I guess yeah definitely I
wish I knew some retarded people I guess
that's just one of your fascinations
right now I've got like man the world is
such a curious place there's so many
things to be they have to be joking
about certain things that only they get
right right yeah look within their own
context this is a snack time or
something like that yeah you're right I
like snacks too sitting in your in your
Dookie and all that stuff okay moving
along
masturbating seven times a day as an
adult that's who we get to do the cow
milk business
Jesus yeah now you're thinking ways that
the other do you have the other retarded
thing you mentioned which one this about
about yeah yeah yeah yeah why don't you
read it so people don't just hate you as
much yeah becoming very unlikable this
so it says if you would read the full
email says hey Hitler and water champ
Tommy
I laid awake pondering the idea that if
two retarded people had a child could
she or he be don't assume the gender
right
could they be not retarded how would
their up Grammy upbringing be do they
become retarded because of how they see
their parents ask Jesus Christ you never
told me is it that a nature nurture
question it's a valid way that's an
interesting thing okay now ah man that
is Sean from New Jersey you're a fucking
piece of shit John but that's pretty
funny
first of all let's get this out of the
way I don't think and I'm not an expert
but I don't think that like I know two
dwarfs yes can produce a non dwarf
exactly exactly
to mentally like two people with Down
syndrome can can have somebody I don't
know if they can conceive together
period but that definitely don't think
they could consent like what's up with
you guys I don't know what else are they
I do their reproductive are they staring
yeah yeah I think so yeah maybe baby
like it's like in math two negatives
make a positive
oh man okay let's posit this theory okay
let's see then you have like a nun and
nuns what the fucking word what's the PC
shit to say now a non challenge a non
mentally challenged person but then you
are raised by to Malaysia and that's all
you knew like it would be like you'd be
like you wanna come over for dinner and
like what you have any like strawberry
jam guys like that cuz there's stories
of like Russian children being raised by
feral wolves or something in that
Ganesha yes it's very possible it's a
good theory
so you're saying then then the
able-bodied person like that if they
were raised exclusively by mentally
challenged people they know yes nature
nurture did we well let's put a call out
there to our audience if you've seen
that scenario take place in life we'd
love to hear more about it it's a good
idea Jean well we're two special people
and we very much are who knows our kids
gonna turn out oh right now let's move
on to another important thought provoker
okay this one makes me laugh this is
from a girl
Gianna she writes dear mommies I eat
like shit and I'm constantly having
diarrhea but we'll do nothing to change
my habits because because one I really
like bread and - I think diarrhea is the
only way I remain skinny
what is your opinion on this can this be
true this Diary activity
[Applause]
I mean okay first you're like that's
stupid but then if you think about it if
you think about it of course the
diarrhea is keeping her skin it's
helping it's definitely helping because
if you think back all those drugs like
fen phen didn't that give you diarrhea
or something back in the 90s I know I
had lobster chips
Oh lean the aleene's would give you
diarrhea and you wouldn't digest it and
that would keep you skinny so I'm gonna
go yet I got food poisoning from Lobster
yeah in high school yeah and I lost 22
pounds in eight days there you go yeah
you should have done that for the fat
challenge just get got fucking food
poisoning yeah I can't believe back then
when the fat challenge that we didn't do
hot yoga we definitely showed a lot of
weight yeah it's fucking sucks yes so
much I don't know how you're doing it
honestly I fucking cry the whole time no
I hate it I hate exercise I just forced
myself to do Pilates but then the hot
stuff fuck that fucking don't you feel
like you're dying all the time like
don't feel like you're gonna pass out
sometimes yeah
the last 15 minutes of every class of my
maybe I'll die right now
has anyone blacked out like has anyone
passed out during hyo's not in the
classes I've been in but I'm sure if you
were to pull a bigger group of people
yeah yeah like one guy emailed me he's
like I started going to I'm only leaving
class like three times in the in the 90
minutes how about you and I'm like don't
leave at all he was like I don't know
how that works well don't you have like
you've gotten it kind of an abusive
teacher which I don't think you're
supposed to and yoga they're not
supposed to force you into poses and
stuff right so like okay I went ten
years ago and when I went ten years ago
it was like they were like do what you
can yeah water whenever you want rest if
you need if you feel overwhelmed it's
fine so I was like that's what this was
like we walk in the first time I reach
my water the guy goes sir
and I was like what and he goes we don't
just take water breaks I'll let you know
when and I was like oh I don't like that
then we were in a pose and he was
telling some story and his these two
ladies were talking and and he knew one
of them he was Meredith Zipit I talking
to a little kid you know and I was like
that's funny but I didn't like when he
said he was like Tom I know you can get
your arms that's yeah we're doing
overhead he goes Tom do your arms
straighten all the way out or not and so
I did and I was like and he goes oh so
they do and I was like yeah he was like
try to do that and then it was at an
indian guy named god i'm in argyll and
he goes got him have you given up on
sit-ups entirely and and I'm sitting
there like alright man and then he goes
I guess sit-ups for you are like arms
for Tom they're not supposed to do that
the whole thing is not to force yourself
to do what other people are doing we
just I just fucking rolled with it and
then he I'm just like all right this
guy's a fuckin asshole
so all these teachers like between poses
sometimes look if you like their own
philosophy you know they'll just start
talking so like like one lady was like
you know if you smoke you really got to
think about it it's gonna smell when you
come in here and that's something you
should really give thought to do I want
to be disrespectful to everybody else in
my class so shit like that so this guy
the guy that likes Zing's he goes you
know it took my son to New York and we
were we were we arrived on the on the
red-eye so he walked his friend to class
and after a block his he's my son said
to me daddy my legs are tired and then
he goes and arms straight coming in
lings up they're done and pose up and
hold it and so then we get into another
position and it's
like no one talks I'm just laying there
and I go hey what's up with the rest of
that story yeah and then I see Burton
birthday like I felt like fifth grade
again I was well he goes did he tell the
story he like turned or he was like what
I know you didn't finish that story he
goes that was the end of the story your
storytelling fucking sucks man like that
is not the end of a story is not yeah
that is not an email came in says what's
up my Ma's I've recently noticed a lot
of talk about Tom's obsession with death
and I think his obsession may be
cultural like Tom I'm of Hispanic
descent and growing up my mother was
obsessed with murder shows it became a
family event it was a lot of fun to
guess who did it and at the end you got
satisfaction when they got caught even
more so if you guessed the killer
correctly it was game like I have
discussed this with some of my other
Hispanic friends and it seems to be a
reoccurring trend we have come to the
conclusion that Spanish people just like
to gossip and someone's death murder and
funeral is hot gossip or at least it was
in my small Spanish community much love
from London Ontario hashtag fake London
well is that true yes it is I mean I've
never been around people that love
gossip more than all of my like the
Latin side of my family they are such
gossips I don't know that they like
death but they love a story of like
someone's downfall like I can't I can't
say that it's like they're less they're
less like everybody loves gossip you
know but like they're less ashamed of it
they're like come here I guess like it's
like dinner conversation here about know
we're like my dad's side of the family
would be like they would be you know
they'd pull you aside American proper my
family its opposite we like to hear
about the bad news yeah yeah oh did you
hear about so say what it has a brain
tumor is going to die and like
want to fucking know that I should do
does he get excited so and so lost his
legs no it's like they just want to
share the bad news that you feel like
shit too I feel like that's our cult
like the Eastern Bloc or shit is like we
need you to be depressed too
yeah I don't know I feel like the with
with my like the Spanish side they're
just more they like telling you have
someone fucked up and they're like yes
actually if if that person was feeling
himself for a second and they really
yeah like you know so and so it has that
nice car oh shit you lost it it's gone
now just shows you if you buy nice cars
they'll go away
like what don't try all like Catholic
guilt stuff yeah like you thought you
were better than nice yeah
remember have so-and-so had two homes he
can't afford it anymore yeah like that's
nice that's so funny yeah yeah yeah I
know I think ours we just like the
bummer of it you want to hear a
completely so we've always you know
we've featured like vocal fry' yeah
different different speech patterns on
this show you know Megan and I have been
together for nearly three years she's a
beautiful girl whatever dude
never met a guy that speaks like that
there's another guy who's doing YouTube
videos about all kinds of shit but
listen this is one of the most unique
speech patterns I've ever heard that I
can't like it doesn't even add up with
this dude how where he learned to speak
is when I'm fascinated with Texas has
really been on my mind a lot lately
and I wanted to honor this state in my
own way with a countdown I respectfully
dedicate this list to everyone who has
been affected by Hurricane Harvey
he might have grown up with two retarded
parents in motion nailed it I mean
seriously know what it kind of sounds
like you know like those art like
remember how Stephen Hawking used to
talk and his robot voice like I can see
all the flowers in like fits like he
learned from a robot you think yeah it
sounds like it's like one of those
people like dude I'm smoking there is
nothing more terrifying than that yeah
that is funny we're gonna play that
daily for our son right around fifth
grade sixth grade what our cigarettes
would be like these are saying rents I
know I know and then like for cocaine
are like for drugs like show the people
like their noses you know like an eats
Karam there's cocaine yeah listen this
dude this alleged ghost was caught on
video rummaging around a property of an
arcade in Dallas glides over the grass
quickly fits through an entranceway it's
pretty convinced it's all of inflexion
are wrong oh yes it's like opposite day
yeah yeah the great tragedy in Dallas
this famous Museum in San Antonio has
any pieces of history and a wealth of
strings nothing it Tonio is no it's not
you say it parents is that night workers
often hear their name called have their
clothing tugged on time see a
transparent ghost that they think
originated from one of the many ancient
Native American artifacts on display
yeah weird if you knew that guy I swear
it like it would it would unnerve you
you yeah you guys start changing the way
you speak what happened like that blue
band is that one of the ghosts haunting
us cuz we're mocking his fuckin
one of your staff just alright that's so
funny dude it does sound like a computer
like an updated Stephen Hawking speaking
spell voice isn't that also fascinating
to you they're like one of the smartest
guys on earth yes can't communicate well
can't communicate but put through a
machine no because he knows the secrets
to the universe and God had to be like
stop talking it's true he's like you're
too smart shut up now you sound like
like a Latin mother right now it was
like hurricanes because God is angry
isn't that crazy you really think that
mo Diggs
people do think that that it's because
God's punishing us so crazy
your mother-in-law thinks that right I
try not to think about it though yeah I
tried ain't no she's like old-school
though Tommy no I know under yeah oh
yeah I'm like when you hear that when
you're talking to your own mom who's
like god he's upset like at this like
when I was 21 fuck are you talking abut
now I'm like yeah no I know he's fucking
pissed
I don't like gonna fuckin waste energy
having that argument and see isn't that
the essence of maturity is when that is
getting tired that's the essence of
authority yes would just exhaust yes to
explain how that's not happening like
guys not like fuckin get them with
weather patterns it's not happening so I
just go I don't we're gonna be better
people you're totally right I hope he
doesn't get more pissed this week all
right I love you bye
it's so true I've just learned to let it
go like let other people's insanity go
this week in the South you know
culturally we all know I'm an elitist I
love LA fuck you know never leave ya
California is the best there's no reason
to leave Anna and just like
I love it I love it here and now you
know at the South Justice on my culture
and I was just hearing but like the way
they they're nice people they're not bad
people but just culturally it's so
different and I was like well yeah well
you know fuck two tears in a bucket
bucket or whatever like just a lot of
apathy and the culture you know like but
what's good to eat here well there's a
wild weightings down the street like I'm
knocking I'm 41 years old I'm not gonna
go to fucking Wild Wings for dinner you
go to well wings you know what I mean
I'm just an adult like I can't like well
we know I don't I can't eat that shit
before I perform later for fun every now
and then remember one time where we were
in we did that southern right yes that's
what I was thinking of a new Bama
Birmingham yeah and we were so depressed
cuz we were in Birmingham and then we
went and we went to Wild Wings and
bought like one of every flavor yeah
literally because you know you think it
like they you're like how much is an
order and they're like well it's like
you get like five wings and you're like
that's nothing so I was like yeah just
like hook me up dude like run through it
and he was like you want one of every
flavor and I was like I think so and
then we get back to the room and I start
setting them up and she's like how many
wings you get I think like like 60 and
you literally have I don't know like
eight and you're like I'm pretty good so
yeah you got thirty five wings left over
but the point is my point being I could
have judged them and get all upset and
be like why aren't they like think you
know why aren't they more like me but
then I was like I gotta let that shit go
bro ya fuckin let it go you let it go
let them do you because I was too tired
and exhausted like you said surety yeah
fucking kid at home I don't give a shit
you're like God I don't pay these people
back and he'll fucking I don't believe
people they'll say God God will pay
these people back with a
a storm yeah they'll get theirs gods I
know yeah I got Oh God look from above
looks down
[Music]
that's God I know that's God watching
people do he decides who gets it yeah it
is so the older I get when people God
probably got upset and you're like okay
so did the Easter Bunny - yeah we do it
you know obviously this is its pastor
yeah he's a pastor he he thinks that God
is reigning fury on the gays right yeah
yeah cuz there's come in the Starbucks
remember he was the guy saying no no oh
that's a different guy oh that's a
different guy that's yeah that's a
different pet that guy thinks that there
is jizz in Starbucks the guy that you're
thinking that's not the hell nah guy but
that guy also in the same video that he
says there's semen and your Starbucks
said be careful if you drink Starbucks
cuz you just might get pregnant right
cuz if you swallow cheese you might
that's how babies are made so so you
know so we do a lot of you know on the
sayings and this week we had a you feel
me it's always a nice one it's a variant
yeah so you feel me pretty closely you
know I'm saying no take a shit you know
how much they were trying to attack and
go at you tonight no I killed my damn
self you feel me I should have kept back
coloring on that first touch now you
said me got a little push in the back
masseuse it's the game of football you
for me now this is norcal all the way
like he's you feel me
oh fuck yeah he's from Oakland yes I
came out and I was hella weak today you
think I gave up two tugs but she we came
out to victory so I'm gonna take it as a
as a learning experience she from we
don't talk it up and go in the meeting
room and Dan you for me kick back chill
relaxed so crazy
I fucking love interviews like where
somebody doesn't and you caused a fumble
at the end of the game what someone
doesn't just give like straight up the
foot I mean they're like whoa
as I watched and like because I feel
like how do they hold their shit
together to give those interviews
because if it were me I'd be like this
guy I don't know what fuckin that's was
like that's not thinking about the fact
that this is nationally televised yeah I
wouldn't either
well I don't know most people that's the
thing is that most of them do most of
them are like oh yeah you know team the
team we win as a team we lose as a team
and like that and you're like oh really
and then what else he's like well you
know we don't if anything bad happens is
you can't just blame one guy like they
all do this guy's like I fucked up I
fucked my own shit up of course and
Justin got there for the tester how do
you feel about that
that made my game go from hello week to
week I'm just weekend hella next week I
get back on my shit though so that's
right
yeah definitely NorCal hella hell yeah
[Music]
yeah hell yeah
I never heard hella until I did I swear
it like I never heard it like it's part
of the wax concho I did the San Jose
improv where I was walking out of the
hotel
I was I was cooking something to eat and
then one of the hotel workers was like
oh sandwich shop over there's hella good
you should eat that shit and I was like
oh is it and he's like yeah man there's
no hella good place on boiling second
Street and then once it like entered I
was like oh then I heard everybody say
it yeah nobody there in the 90s it was
like full pumpin everybody was saying
how I do this fucking hella awesome is
hella hella hella there was a girl on
our floor in the dorm rooms we just
called her hella because she said it so
much I don't even know her fucking name
or like what's up hella memory where you
like your fucking overalls your denim
overalls
bell-bottom like one off if you were
dope tank-top shit shit
you guys want to try a you know I think
it's time for my Pinot Grigio oh shit
today my sober October I don't give a
fuck man get a glass of Pinot Grigio or
anyone thank you mommy I why not it's my
day off do it you know what is it gonna
be hard for you to watch me drink oh
yeah I'm fucking freaking out right now
you white knuckling mmm
I'm never it's never gonna be hard to
not drink booze Thanks hard for me to
not to drugs will I ever stop wearing
cool hats never well what happened to
the Hat good question time I lost it I
lost it but you know what that means I'm
gonna buy fucking six more of this
alright but I feel like it's not fair
because you made me gave up my art
teacher jacket remember that I started
on that the art thank you plus I was fat
I was hiding some baby weight
see no you liked it that Jack is not a
goodness well can I go back to my art
teacher - look if you get your hat
that's only fair thank you I I still
don't know on that that's not fair
what do you mean what do I get in
exchange thank you thank you sir
thank you very much you sure do I get to
go Morgoth can I get more witchy yeah
you can get it yeah go for that I can
fuck a witch good I don't want the uh
I'm gonna read by all my goth shirt do
it alright the art teacher Jack is right
no that's just not cool yeah that's a
hell of a jacket so do you guys want to
try a master of accents translation yeah
great alright here is a Scottish one
these are these are so far so let's see
how is this English and I
it translated so as we go throw it once
if you got it you're amazing and then
I'll tell you what's actually being said
okay Darrow clue 0 ab 0 clue not even an
inkling nothing right because it was a
believer
so he says fucking Scotland why don't
you shut your fucking mouth I'll explain
to you pal
right ok it's gibberish
[Music]
whoa that really is what he's saying
like once you know once you once I say
it you get you're like that's actually
did you hear it no really I just it
sounds like a dog barking wait listen
know what I'm saying all right
that's like he says like something
fucking Scotland why don't you shut your
fucking mouth I'll explain to you pal
right all right damn fucking squeaky
pass
[Music]
okay something about the fucking tele
way definitely says fuck a lot I can
confirm that yeah I'm on a fucking vomit
no I'm not fucking sorry Kelly just
fucking Scotland you start fucking early
in the fucking morning okay and you want
to fucking tell me the fucking Scotland
are called one fucking Scotland so they
are and do you want me to fucking tell
you you can fucking anywhere so you can
okay well I mean this is crazy it's real
crazy and it was translated by a
Scottish guy for us and it's definitely
I don't want to hear it again
so that's terrible let's do the this one
here is shorter okay
who I'm not gonna say I'll just let you
hear it and see if it's in
[Music]
isn't it crazy fucking cut you got that
isn't it nuts that all of us and that
guys speak the same language nothing no
but that guy's on another planet like
you definitely got it right there's the
last word it's content you're right yeah
you're a master I don't need to hear
that again
here's somebody that sent us in coming
out of their colonoscopy no no you just
love to get one by the way you snuck out
of it last year and then you've not
rescheduled yeah but you know what ever
since I cut out sugar I don't have
monster fucking shits like that anymore
I think I was always like I was like the
skinny girl who was like but then I cut
sugar out that's true since you've
cleaned up your diet you haven't had
those blasters yeah yeah like as much
but I think what age do you have to
start doing that as a guy no you guys
you get a prostate exam at 40 okay
colonoscopies I don't know alright 50 53
shoot yeah when they get up in there and
then the doctor is like oh I'm gonna eat
your scrub and then they do it over so
here's this lady coming out of her
colonize this is a lady just got that
moose soup smokers yeah yeah that smoker
laughs that is a real tree there she is
there she is there she okay would you
rather get your passenger yeah yeah
you gotta eat the scrum on the Moose
oubli oh my god or the colonoscopy lady
Oh think about it quite fresh
no one's no I mean one's fresh out of a
colonoscopy so Jesus that's why the game
is so hard
[Music]
she's gnarly yeah I know that's um one
point so which one do you choose
probably the musu Blade II yeah yeah
what the Moose's lady yeah yeah she is
special there is serving yeah there's
something like cuz you know eras Matic
about her you know she also gives you
feedback like you're you know yeah
you're not just like hanging out there
like oh like you're doing it and she's
fucking you know like you put your mouth
down there and she's alright at least
you appreciate you doing yeah that's
true she does give you feedback yeah an
approval yeah good job tom
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah whatever whatever
John tasted like mousse ooh Oh actually
that's not bad I'm gonna be good I bet
it tastes better than the fart lady like
ya know do you want to do we do would
you rather all right sure this would be
fun
this is super gross what I had sitting
here I somebody it's too disgusting
intrigued the audience
nothing's too gross for our show the
show was about here's a beer imagine a
woman of your dreams your object of
desire though charm her sensuality her
passion try her taste feel her smell
hear her voice this is for a beer hold
on now free your fantasies and imagine
that with a magic wand you can close it
in one bottle of beer we have discovered
a process of transmission of her essence
of her femininity her instincts by
isolation of lactic acid bacteria from
her vagina it's all use but and gross I
told you that this is a company called
Yanni they make beer with bacteria from
the vagina of supermodels and this line
is titled bottled instinct that our
laboratory isolates and multiplies the
bacteria in a safe way additionally we
examine the final bacteria in terms of
its purity and safety so you're like Oh
making like this sweet girl's pussy beer
right now like dude men are nasty yeah
that's nasty as hell
it's fucking pretty wild nasty that's
super gross super fucking gross okay I
don't know there's no woman that's like
[Music]
okay all right I have to see a therapist
about this know that now
like there's no player selected
beautiful Czech model Alex a brand over
to be our source of the Yanni
I'd be the source how much money do you
want for that who cares he's like you
take a cup of pussy swabs fifty bucks
you got it make these fifty bucks
quick it's a great way to promote my
special yeah you guys want my yoni beer
watch my special that's my special and
drink from my box yeah rate it put it in
your cue you know it's funny my dad in
the 80s he used to get those beers that
you'd scratch the tits you know the
scratch off what no no no he don't know
from our liquor store and it's a beer
bottle and you could scratch her it was
a scratch her part and you could see
like the chicks tits that's from that
guy's my childhood was awesome it sounds
like you guys are the weird ones here
and oh no I said think that was really
fun too it's on the beer bottle yes it
was like a scratch deal with it some
German shit oh yeah not American yeah no
she didn't think that was but I did we
talking about scratch your tits and yeah
you can see her tits those crazy that's
wild yeah I'm sure this is definitely
another lovely
therapist about that but they're like
pussy swab beer and like disgusting dude
that's nastiest bug all right here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
drink the top layer
[Music]
all right jeans here we go we're gonna
start off mild and then we'll get to
varsity level shit all right Tommy
would you rather yep be Burt's liver or
his heart Tyrel good would you rather no
no yeah it's hard right shit I mean
here's this thing about it's just like
endless endless flowing booze or it's so
hard yeah it really does work you'd be
fucking exhausted
yeah from like you're like another
fucking potatoes and soda do like yeah
surrounding the morning gasping for air
drowning all the time now doesn't
deliver regenerate itself so you can
repair yourself that's its regenerative
Bjork wood that's how you get a break
once every 44 years right sober October
yeah right what's in here right now his
livers like wasn't happy yeah first like
breathe yeah or his heart
it's caring around 335 and got the food
you got the running the panting the
there's a layer of fat right around it a
one yeah yeah I don't know I guess it'd
be a little more fun to be his liver I
think I would go with the liver just to
like it would just be like it's kind of
like that's his liver is living like
birds life philosophies so you just go
out like yeah go harden cuz the heart is
not gonna be fun
the hearts gonna be a nightmare at least
so much whoever yeah yours liver you're
having a good time
you're enjoying yourself you're up
closing every bar in every city where he
was performing and might as well have a
few laughs
yeah I go with you on this one yeah
actually all right guys clap for ring
Burt's liver yeah okay applause for
Burt's heart who wants to be Birds heart
yeah it's part of job why would you
wanna be his heart sir yeah sorry you
guys pull the plug whenever Jesus
you want to kill Burt is that you're
saying he's like no drunk with power huh
yeah yeah you have way more power as the
heart so I might have been a lapse of my
own judgment I want to go back I want to
be as hard okay it's definitely a harder
yeah I want to be uh sorry I'm with you
I'm sorry love to give you panic attacks
okay here's my other one I like this one
okay okay would you rather legally
change your last name to Hitler that's
really cool it's a pain in the ass too
if you ever change your name fuck and
like you have to like don't you like
make a case for it too don't just like
file a case you know but I mean used to
be like Hitler like and the guys like
I'm sorry you like Hitler yeah yeah you
have to go to Social Security office the
DMV it's a fucking pain there at the end
like congratulations mr. Hitler your
dream is now a reality
Tom Hitler and then now you're Tom
Hitler special comedian yeah it's great
to be here yeah yeah please welcome
Paige yeah oh wow this is a nice ring to
it
what's the other awesome option okay or
every time you speak it's in baby talk
like how our two-year-old talks back but
that back out how sighs he goes like
that so I have to do stand-up like that
yeah just walk out and go be a fun hour
to watch wouldn't it yeah well I feel
like life is like they both make your
life really awful so a good job on that
you got it but one of them makes your
life impossible right the baby talk you
can't do it like with the hip first of
all there's a lot of times when you meet
people where they don't have to know
your last name
not in your biz olestra but also like
when you you know you walk into get buy
a coffee they're not like you don't
think be like by the way I'm hit call me
hit look you're not to say that
whatever yeah I think they'd be like get
the fuck out of our store right now so
that's that's fantastic
what if it's I can't believe I'm saying
it but I would definitely I would rather
be Hitler than then talk like that yeah
I think yeah okay and what's suck like
people here's the thing you can't tell
people why you've changed your last name
and Hitler that's a caveat of the thing
I think they would make some assumptions
don't you if you're like I'm not
explaining it they're like I think I
have a pretty good idea big fan of
charlottesville are you and you right
now
Oh kind of want those statues back bro
so yeah so you're gonna take Hitler as
your last name yeah I mean okay what if
I made it like you're talking but at a
first grade level it's still like life
is over
like with a hillier thing you at least
you know people get upset with you all
the time people would be like the fuck
you know what the fuck is wrong with you
but you could at least you know have a
conference like you could talk your way
around it around though yeah if you
speak in baby-talk yeah it's over
you just you could do things in pictures
you could be like pictures yeah hear me
out
like pictures in picture yes the picture
comic I mean fucking Demetri Martin made
a living out of like drawings and shit
not to compare him he's a very funny guy
but god damn it Demetri Oh four-year-old
Demetri right I mean you know you just
have to change your act a little bit
yeah I'm smashing watermelons whatever
yeah well why don't you what's your
answer I take I take I take Hitler yeah
yeah clash Oh applause for Hitler who
take Taylor yeah applause for Hitler
[Applause]
you don't always hear that but yeah all
right sorry sorry guys I don't really
all right
it would take baby voice add stuff
wait why would you do that yeah first
crates easier than toddler yeah you
think that's okay to communicate in
first grade level yeah all right people
would just think you're endearing and
girls they would not think you can get
away with it if you're a woman first
right check yeah yeah yeah yeah because
then guys would be like she's perfect
yeah she's like yeah tastes good totally
I'm tired I know it's some old rich
boyfriend that's all you need hmm all
right there we go okay Kentucky's why
don't you clip your nails in front of
your panties okay okay would you rather
this is ones more personal to Tom and I
every time we do it it has to be while
our son is crying in the next room the
caveat being like the nanny's there but
he's crying you can hear it like it's
annoying and it's distracting and sad
she's just a child
for everybody else either your child or
if you don't have a child another child
is crying in the next room right next to
you so you're like you're doing it just
bawling right or every time we do it the
dogs get to stay on the bed
and like beef gets really mad when when
like Tom and I hug he starts barking and
thinking that one of us is being hurt
yeah and then bitsy we'll just start
licking you your legs is that I finally
get my scrum big time yeah big time hmm
see the thing is I can tune out the
crying you know so that's a tough one
thank God I can't I can't I you do
normally tune out the crying it's
amazing how you never seem to hear 4:00
in the morning
yeah I'm just programmed you know yeah
hmm do I want to hear those tears do I
want to have a dog bark barking sex oh
I'm gonna go for tears I'm gonna go for
tears yeah wow those are the real the
real men in the room right now all right
you guys clap if you'd rather hear a
baby crying as you're trying to make
love to your spouse
okay how about having two small dogs on
your bed at the same time yeah you want
to fuck with those dogs on the bed come
on every time like you're moving and the
dogs like licking you're like no and I
go all the time super annoying yeah
fevers are relentless - shut up and you
get into like one position you really
like and then you'd be like what the
fuck how are you in my armpit and then
you look down the dock like I'd still
take the dogs I can I cannot do my baby
crying it was like primal like I hear it
my uterus starts like quivering you know
like I just think we're a wired
difference to me it is arousing like I
kind of like it you know
that's all I got that's it that's it huh
let's see retarded blind when you fill
her up yeah sure let's fill her up
let's see oh shut alright let's go here
we go here we go here we go okay okay
now since we're getting into hallo jeans
yeah
yes very scary time of year I thought it
would be nice if we could do a filler up
steal her shut spooky edition yes so
let's start with the dudes
I'm gonna go Edward Scissorhands you
guys know the fuck that is Johnny Depp I
know it's kind of an older reference so
I don't know if you guys know okay or
Herman Munster that's even older
fuck the monsters describe him
so Herman Munster looks like
Frankenstein for those of you don't know
like it's supposed to be Frankenstein
and then Edward Scissorhands is just
hot-ass Johnny Depp with some fucking
blades on his fingers you know I'm
saying and like Johnny before he started
drinking and hanging out with
what's-his-name Stanhope well yeah
before I started looking like a fucking
pirate like now he's crazy yeah I keep
Richards Yankees who I was actually
before he started drinking $30,000 of
wine a week yeah I mean do you ever see
Edward penis hands yeah I'm sorry yeah
she did she saw it she wanted it yeah I
know that was there was made like in
that era right it was like made right
back then and it was a like their parody
right it was like and did he was he like
it was everything yeah
how would you feel about that yeah
here's a weird thing though is that
every Scissorhands he's gonna hurt you
he's gonna even though he's hot as
Johnny Debs
he's Edward put his hands in this I'm
gonna go Herman Munster because what No
yeah first of all he's got that big old
Frankenstein hog on him and yeah he's
probably gonna be got green goo it's
gonna be fun and interesting what a
nasty ID he had back oh that weird laugh
you know you'd be doing him kind of a
favor he'd be super grateful Edward
Scissorhands he's highly you can get
whoever so he's naked
that's the whole thing dude he's still
fuckin Johnny then no but you watch them
he's that guy doesn't that's the thing
is that everyone's so scared of him he
would be super fucking appreciative you
know and then you're getting double the
payoff because people are so scared of
getting hurt by him right and if you
were actually like I'm a fucking choke
on this thing and and you're just like
keep your hands away and you actually
get him to do it
you're getting double the pay off you're
getting an appreciative little fucking
model looking guy
[Music]
I'm still going Herman and I like him
cuz he's sweet I'm chewing on them out
on that young fucking deaf dick for sure
I'd go Johnny Depp but like early
Pirates of the Caribbean that's not this
scenario no I know but I like what's
your favorite Johnny Depp era let's be
honest favorite era like when Z the
hottest for you
I don't know I mean yeah Johnny watch
crazy that's the thing he probably was
self-aware that he knows he's a
good-looking dude in that era he doesn't
have the I'm an international movie star
air about him so that's probably the
best there to be with him the newly
famous newly like he's just like yeah
yeah like hanging out on the Sunset
Strip
just do it blow that's different than
like ten years ago Johnny where he's
just like look if I'm gonna come I need
a mouth on each ball I need a mouth on
my dick I need 10 miles around my hat
like just story that's how I'm gonna get
hard and you're like Jesus you're pretty
demanding like do you think that's what
it's like for him now for sure yes yeah
yeah it's like well some girls like I
don't know if I can leave my four
friends and he's like your four friends
are fucking coming or I'm not coming
that's how it's gonna crazy what reality
to be believe it his reality it's gotta
be rageous outrageous yeah it's not even
conceivable and it's okay with him and
not with half because half was gross I
feel like you have this very loves have
I know your subset was he your dad or
something what's the finding all right
I'm gonna go Herrmann this is a weird
thing like culturally half yeah but I
mean like it's weird to that like I
don't know like you get you kind of get
how people are like you're the man right
like everybody was like yes
yeah he's wearing PJs so the comics dude
that's what we do for a living he wore C
wore silk jammies and an ascot yeah and
he's in his fucking captain's hat it's
not dude bust the nuts and those silk
jammies yeah
Holle that had to be kind of rough
though these last 20 years to take that
nut if you were yes yeah because you
know he probably presses a button
extender down the hall exactly for Jam
we have to act like they're excited
that's the thing that's right we're
excited in the 70s yeah yeah what's up
sit on the end of the bed I want to see
your twat yeah it's the faking of it
yeah
spread them did we vote did we do this
booth which one oh no we didn't vote
well I said Johnny I'm gonna stir on
stir like a fucking psycho and then what
about the audience who was who what's
Edward Scissorhands Johnny Depp that's a
lot of ladies cheering who wants the
green gobbler Herman Munster that huge
dick huge dick yeah how do you know what
Johnny's good I don't think it's that
big not like Herman Herman was a big
dude yeah what do you think Johnny's
packing mmm average just a regular dog
regular dick but a hot face dude yeah
you know cuz you'd hear about it I feel
like he's banging enough hot people his
big dudes get around like Milton Berle
had a huge yeah who's who's people talk
about the what's the guy from Mad Men
yeah jon Hamm's apparently got fucking
two hams between his legs
and the the surfer guy
the famous was like Kelly Slater that
guy's got like a loaf of bread see
thanks yeah that's what I'm saying like
word spreads about your dick size you
fucking and that people are like how do
you know Tom well there's a reason they
call me
[Music]
yeah I'll find me don't you worry about
it all right we got to wrap this okay so
for the ladies okay it's Morticia Addams
and I'm talking like the the recent one
like from the anjelica huston
yeah describe for people that okay oh
wait she's got like she's tall and
skinny and she wears like the type nice
black dress she's got kind of a big nose
but that's fine and she's got like you
know red lips like kind of Gothic style
yeah God and then or Winona Ryder in
beetlejuice but she's got that teenage
angle so it might be underage I don't
know if one yeah about that babe it's
illegal it's illegal what do you mean
it's illegal okay but Morticia Saul
woman like she's of age she's got babies
and shit hid situations all right yeah
no we don't know forever that's why I
know what Johnny Depp would take on this
one I know that's right she's a little
shoplifter you pull her in the back room
like let me look in your bags you're in
big trouble there's only one way out of
this stupid fucking Winona for sure yeah
well no no right yeah who's who's for
Morticia anyone any Angelica Houston
okay okay Winona where's my win on us
yeah she's the best dude she's so pretty
she was always so skinny and gangly with
those huge cans remember like reality
bites and she had those fucking knockers
on her man she wouldn't wear bras and
shit in the movies that's how you know I
got a nice tits we didn't have to wear a
bra and you've got like D cups I
definitely remember don't worry about it
I remember guys we have to wrap up this
has been a super fun thanks for coming
James and we we have we always we love
you guys thank you for coming to our
show Thank You gene
[Applause]
yeah we really appreciate it we'll
definitely do it again we'll be out
there if anyone wants to come say hi
we'll be out there come say hi and again
thank you very much for coming to the
library have a wonderful night have a
wonderful week and we'll see you on the
next one good night
[Applause]
[Music]